okay first of all what are we going to
do about your mom and your credit cards
like are we cutting her off is it you
know what i can i can attempt but uh she
has a lot of
um
she has a lot of
external sources oh
to
you know she get around she knows my
business manager's number oh she knows
my manager's number my booking agent wow
my wife's
assistants
so she just
yeah it's deeply layered at this point
she gets the credit cards what is she
buying
um what does she like the most
knickknacks
collectibles
starburst
cigarettes
nah but we
you know i think she posted where she
went out shopping
am i talking too loud sorry
hey lana you're doing great man you're
doing great over there have you ever
been
well but but the um yeah she
she uh today
she loves flowers and so a couple couple
i think she posted it where she got my
credit card and went and loaded up the
back of her
um
she spent a lot good adorable nah she
she has fun and as long as she can be
out in the yard whatever you know you
know how you how you do is
as a son she uh
you know i've been really blessed to be
able to look after my mama like she
looked after me and and so um
it's you know mother's day is always a
special day and
hopefully where wherever you're at mama
you're uh you're spending some of my
money
[Laughter]
i would love to hear it i'd love to hear
it
so it's a special mother's day episode
very emotional for everyone what would
you say is the greatest lesson you've
learned from your mom
oh the greatest lesson i've learned
from my mom i mean
gosh you know
i grew up watching my mother read her
bible every night in her in her tv room
she'd been there underlining little
letters and passages
i just learned love from her i mean i
learned tough love i mean she didn't
um you know when when i was
when i did something wrong i i i got
dealt with and when i do something right
i got loved on and so i think that's i
think
um i knew my mother wasn't my friend i
knew she was my mother yeah and uh so
she's kind of taught me
how to how to
be nurturing and loving and scratch the
backs and all that and you know when i
was sick you know
um
when i was six she always got me banana
popsicles oh i love bananas so now i try
to go get my children banana popsicles
when they have a stomach bug yes oh and
you have two contestants that were sick
with covid but they made it through
they actually didn't they actually it
went well um
from the um it went well from their
hotel room obviously and
with with with like i said katie said it
out there today she's like we're still
dealing you know we're still dealing
with this and and yes we are but i think
um
i think
you know the challenges of covet are
gonna
we're gonna be dealing with it for a
long time and i think the show was able
to really put together they obviously
put the kids in a great position to do
well and
and um glad we could give them the
the proper performance that they deserve
i love that thank you for your time it
was so nice talking to you yeah good to
talk to you